with the g-league and it was announced
today that they are going to start back
up
in a disney bubble starting in february
so it is a family affair tonight we got
the balls we got the van gundy's and we
so he helps and he compliments their
best players
you saw borrego there he's now in his
third season as ingram swishes home a
three
way off and that one is graham
bonzo ball running the floor gets two
and it's a 10-4 start for the pelicans
[Applause]
[Music]
and williamson turns it over lamella
ball with the pick
and the nice feed in transition to terry
rozier for two
did a great job of hitting alexander
walker
as we see the turnover there by
williamson playing in traffic
that turns into the transition but
getting back to ingram
where his improvement has been the best
part is his three-point shooting game a
beautiful pass
by ball to biambo if you're the older
brother guarding the younger brother
there should be no flagrant fouls you
should be able to do whatever you want
to it
[Applause]
would you have been okay with that
considering stan's two years older than
you i didn't get
interviewed right tonight like at the
end of the first because they're the
home team
right so he's got to wait till the third
quarter we'll see what the score is
there wow miles bridges
absolutely abuses the rim beers with
orlando and three with miami
that is some dunk right there late
rotation by heart
get the edge that time here's ball
penetrating
keeps it what a move great leader sets
the tone in the locker room
there's still a ways away as a bell
again ball again shows off incredible
skill level hit him in practice well
that's a beautiful left-hand finish
here's lonzo ball from outside and he
drains it
brother lonzo is out there but they're
not guarding one another lanza was
supposed to be guarding rozier there
and rozier knocks down his second three
of the half
lamelo rookie third overall 19 years old
lonzo in his fourth season 23 years old
lamela with a nice fine the three is
good from bridges and it's a three-point
game
rolled off the rim for hayward
williamson with another rebound his
seventh
here's lonzo williams in the trailer
plays it home
[Applause]
well good find by lonzo ball and the
head of steam
you guys said you want to go to lunch i
said no you you guys go right ahead
continue your comments that's why we
needed the van gundy podcast
[Applause]
here's lamello ball off the bounce steps
into the lane that was sweet
and the pelicans are the number one
rebounding team in the league
[Applause]
lamelo over his brother lonzo hits a
three
nine threes in the quarter
graham trying to shake alexander walker
timers at three here's ball with a kick
out
rozier drains the three and there's the
eighth assist for ball perfect job by
charlotte the entire half of driving it
and searching out the open much higher
expectations coming out because he
played at ucla and obviously was the
first ball brother
and lavar was such a bigger story than
we don't hear from him as much now
that was lamela with a great pass and
the three by hayward